in this video we're going to be talking
all about
audience retention what exactly is
audience retention why does it matter so
much for getting views and succeeding on
youtube and we're going to be revealing
six different tips
for how to rank your videos higher in
search
and getting youtube to actually
recommend your videos i'm also going to
be walking you through an easy tutorial
of
youtube studio where you can see some
important
information for tracking your videos
performance watch time and audience
retention
and then we're also going to be going
through some of these
new insights that youtube has just
showed us
inside of our creator studio so smash
the like button and buckle your seat
belt because this is the coffee with
cannell show
my name is sean cannell and i'm fired up
to talk about
how to trigger the youtube algorithm
with these seven tips for increasing
watch time audience retention
and youtube views if we're just meeting
my name is sean cannell rhymes with
youtube channel
i've grown a couple different youtube
channels to over a hundred thousand one
to over a million
i'm the author of the number one
best-selling book youtube
secrets and i'm most proud of our
students and the people in our community
that we've impacted and helped them
get that silver play button grow their
youtube channels and
ultimately go full time on youtube
that's our mission here at think media
is to help 10 000 purpose-driven people
go
full-time on youtube and one of the keys
to doing that
is ultimately audience retention so
what's the average audience retention on
youtube well according to some reports
the average audience retention on
youtube is between 50
and 60 now audience retention is your
ability to
hold someone's attention on your video
if you look at your analytics which we
will do
shortly there's sometimes the hockey
stick effect where someone clicks on
your video and they're gone immediately
so the question
is how quick how how long can you hold
attention
this is across digital platforms now
have you ever started a netflix show
watched a few seconds or minutes and
thought ah i'm not even going to commit
to this and you bailed well
it didn't keep your attention if a video
that you love
holds your attention you might click on
it and watch it all the way into the end
and watch multiple videos from that
creator
and so some data revealed that if you
can keep someone's attention
over half of the length of your video or
even over 60 percent
you're doing a pretty good job there's a
couple terms we need to know
and and we also need to know why
audience retention is important and
here's some quotes
from youtube themselves they've said
that we've started adjusting the ranking
of youtube videos
to reward engaging videos that
keep viewers watching
type in the comments for me minutes
matter
most that's what's important on youtube
it's not just views because you know a
view can just be one second
but a minute that means you've held
someone for 60
seconds youtube rewards content creators
that create engaging videos and you know
when it comes to engagement
sure likes are okay comments are great
but the most significant signal is
whether or not someone
keeps watching your video that's watch
time that's audience
retention they go on to say that videos
with consistently
high audience retention and watch time
have the potential to show up more
frequently
in search and suggested locations
so not only is having a high
audience retention going to help you
rank your videos in search
it's also going to help your videos be
recommended by the youtube algorithm to
new
viewers so audience retention is very
important
now there's two specific terms that we
need to know to understand this and then
we're going to get into some of these
new features and then i have six tips
for you
and the first one is average view
duration
so this i know there's a lot of
technical terms audience retention
average view duration
well this is the way that youtube kind
of defines audience
retention and it's how many minutes have
people watch your vid videos
average view duration in the case of
this video right here this video has
been viewed
for seven minutes and three seconds and
remember this is on average
because of course some people might
start the video and say ah this isn't
what i thought it was
i'm gonna bail but some people are gonna
watch all the way until the end
so the total combined viewership
averaged down this video is able to hold
viewers attention for seven minutes now
consider this
this video is doing very well and
youtube continues to recommend it to new
people
and therefore on average even people
that potentially don't
know me or haven't seen my content
before their attention is being held
for seven minutes of time in a world
where we can barely have the attention
span
to scroll through instagram or go from
this thing to that thing and we're so
busy
giving your attention for seven minutes
to something is significant
minutes matter most i've seen stats
reveal that the average
view duration on youtube's around five
minutes i think media kind of
hovers between four and five minutes
across all of our videos so
if you start getting to 7 minutes 8 15
and if youtube recommends that video to
new people and you're holding attention
well then of course they would keep
showing it to even more new people
because the avd the average view
duration is significant
the second stat is just another way of
thinking about the same thing
but it's average percentage viewed now
let's say you had a one hour video your
average view duration could be 10
minutes
but that would only be six percent or
whatever
you know 10 minutes out of 60 minutes
would only be 12
or something like that whereas if you
had a 10 minute video
and you had a 50 average percentage
viewed that means it's five minutes so
it's
how long on average are people cr
consuming of the entire video length
and by youtube showing us these two
stats they're revealing to us what they
care about they're saying hey
keep people on the platform for as many
minutes as possible
and then also if you can create videos
that people are getting closer to the
end
of that are that they're watching at
least half the video sixty percent of
the video or higher
then this is like a one-two punch of
audience retention that could really
trigger the algorithm and cause your
videos to be
promoted now youtube has given us
some new insights and they're always up
upgrading the studio
to show us things and when you're on a
specific video
you can come down to key moments and
audience retention
and this chart guide is right here on a
little question mark let me zoom in for
you
and so what we can see is this is
youtube explaining what the chart means
now
it may be self-explanatory but this is
very important
the first thing that it tells us is when
the
line is flat well the first thing it
says a percent greater than 100 percent
may mean that people re-want
rewind and watch the sequence more than
once so if you ever wonder
why is there a spike how could i have or
how could it go
up when it was already going down it
means someone's either clicked bla
clicked back or clicked to that specific
point
but flat is your ideal so this video is
doing very well on think media
and this video is not flat but you can
see it's kind of close
to flat i mean 50 average view duration
which is
great over most people or the
all people that watch it average down to
finishing over half of the video
and there is a gradual decline but by
the end of this video at minute
4 16 38 percent of people are still
watching
so it's not as aggressive this is more
aggressive on this video
but again what it's telling us is that
if you can keep it flat that's what
winning looks like you are literally
holding
keeping in mind too the average person
like if strangers watch the video like
they can't turn away they got to watch
the whole thing gradual decline the
second
thing that youtube defines here means
viewers are losing a bit of attention
over time so then you're saying okay
how can i decrease the slope and i've
got six tips for you in a second
how can i make the decline not as
significant
of course what you don't want is the
hockey stick effect where it just
drops you know really fast
kind of flattens out and maybe only a
couple percent finish the video
next spikes appear when more viewers are
watching
re-watching or sharing a moment or
moments from a video so spikes are these
kind of
it gives us green because green is good
it's sort of these up moments where
maybe
people go to a part rewind from a part
the other reason you might trigger this
is because
of time stamps and we do use time steps
to let people skip through the points
on certain videos and they may get the
idea and they may just kind of click
through to get each time stamp
um that's fine in my opinion because i
want the viewer to just be served at the
highest level i'm not trying to hold
anybody hostage you know so
if they want to click through to the
points but another thing that spikes
could be just telling you is that that's
a very
dense part or popular part here's a
power tip if you've ever seen some
youtubers
and even bo burnham did this on his
recent netflix special
they sometimes flash something so flat
uh so fast kind of like a fight club
thing
they flash a scene or flash a word that
your super fans or any fan may want to
rewind and be like and try to pause it
what was that
and that could create a higher spike of
engagement at that moment
and so that would be the up and then of
course dips mean viewers are
skipping or leaving that specific part
of the video and if i click here
notice it says here's the intro viewer's
still watching around the 30-point mark
which is
this blue section and then it says dip
and if i click the dip it actually skips
to where there is a significant drop
and naturally that's when i'm like well
alrighty then leave me a comment we'll
see you later
and that's going to typically be you
don't want to necessarily let people
know you're ending your video
and once they know it's gone they start
to leave and that makes sense so
uh the biggest thing though is if you
have dips in the middle you want to ask
yourself what can i learn from that dip
you know when we include a brand deal or
a sponsor spot
typically it goes down during that and
it goes back up because people drag
their figure
finger past the sponsor spot let me know
in the comments do you do that
do you listen to podcasts and do you
skip past are you like you know this
person has ads and you're just like i'm
just gonna go to seven minutes man this
is i mean if i'm a little bit into the
interview
i'm just skipping right in i mean that's
natural behavior but these are the types
of things you want to be paying
attention to
so that you can improve your audience
retention and so when you hover over
that question mark
in your on a specific video in your
youtube studio
they'll show you that detail
specifically
so let's look inside of our analytics
and then we'll get to our tips here
and the first thing for measuring
audience retention
um and seeing kind of doing a checkup
from the neck up
of your status is some ways to track how
well you're doing the first
is channel wide avd
that's channel wide average view
duration so if you start in your studio
you go to analytics and then you go to
your engagement
you can see that across all of your
channel
on think media right here we get four
minutes and 12
seconds and that's up in the last 28
days always trying better storytelling
hold more attention have an increased
average view duration so that's kind of
a
macro metric of how are you doing on
your channel think media
in the last 28 days got 3.2 million
views and so that's spread out across
all of those views next is going to be
the top
videos in this period and that's
whatever period that you set
by default it's 28 days let's just say
over the last 365 days for fun in the
upper right hand corner
and then we can see these right here
these are the top videos in the last
year
on think media now notice two things
that it shows us at a snapshot and this
really reveals
what youtube cares about the most it
says
average iteration and it gives us the
total minutes and the percentage viewed
and then it gives us the views it's like
hey this video is getting two minutes
and 27 seconds of average view duration
and it lets you kind of compare
and you can notice that some of these
really big videos i mean this got over a
million views
it keeps getting suggested to new
audiences notice a very low percentage
viewed only 16
but 21 minutes and 16
seconds of total minutes viewed this is
a very longer tutorial it's a longer
tutorial
and so again minutes matter most even
though that's a horrendous percentage
viewed
it's an insane amount of time spent on a
video
and so that is another place that you
can check so to recap
you have channel wide avd average view
duration
you can see the top videos in this
period and be studying
what your average view duration your
average percentage viewed
then you want to go to your top videos
and you can click see
more for even more data so
i'm going to go back to the last 28 days
i'm on engagement inside of youtube
studio
and i'm going to go down to top videos
and say see more
in the back end here we can see a whole
stack of videos
so it goes much more than the top 10 and
it breaks down our click-through rate
our views our average view duration is
shared right here and this is where the
average is coming from four minutes and
12 seconds
across all these videos and i could see
this is interesting the
average view duration on this best
camera q a with
with me is an hour it's insane
like that's crazy uh and and then you
can see some that are maybe only 37
seconds or whatever
so that's another place where you can
dive into your analytics a little bit
deeper
and then finally still watching at 30
seconds and lean in for this one
and hit like if you've been getting
value out of this video because again
this is going to tell us what really
matters to youtube
and so inside of your studio
under engagement scroll down a little
bit you're going to see
key moments for audience retention and
this is significant because this is
showing us
out of our recent uploads how many
people are still watching at 30 seconds
this is very clear about how important
the hook of your video is right
because they're saying if if people are
bailing in the first 30 seconds like
you're in trouble
so in out of our last few videos
our best video has 71 percent of people
still watching after 30 seconds when i
hover over it
we could see that the average iteration
is five and a half minutes
and 40 percent of people basically
consume that one and then it drops to
our worst performing is still four out
of ten people are still watching
at um 30 in the first 30 seconds
sean what does all this data mean and
what are you saying with all of this
information
i'm glad you asked these are signals
when youtube tells us what they're
measuring
then it tells us how we should architect
and craft our content
to get more views and hold more
attention it also
gives us the ability to actually measure
if the tweaks we're making to our
content our videos and our topics are
working and never forget what gets
measured gets improved so i know that
sometimes the data can be overwhelming
but consider studying your data even
looking at it while it feels
overwhelming because you will start to
notice trends and patterns
and places where you can improve your
videos if you're seeing a dip
think about okay how can i trim the
fluff on my next video
improve the audience retention average
view duration
and the more that goes up the more
youtube is going to spread your content
throughout the internet faster than a
tesla
in ludicrous mode hit like if you're
getting value and today's video before
we get into these six tips is brought to
you by
thinkmasterclass.com
and this is a free class we just posted
a brand new update and there's a limited
replay available that you can watch
on demand it's at thinkmasterclass.com
link in the description down
below and in the video uh in the
training it's an hour long training and
i talk about the best ways to make money
on youtube even if you have a small
audience the three biggest mistakes
that youtubers fail and how to avoid
those mistakes
how to grow your channel this year and
some of the new updates to youtube and
the algorithm and so you're gonna love
it it's free
thinkmasterclass.com let's get into the
six
tips tip number one for powering up your
videos
boosting your audience retention is
craft a powerful hook
i won't go into this at length um
because we have some great resources
on this but it's ultimately you really
need to craft
those first 10 20 30 seconds of your
video
you may notice some hooks are even going
much longer hooks of videos
are a minute two minutes now depending
on how long the content is but it's just
thinking that as soon
as the video starts cut to the chase
what does the phrase cut to the chase
mean it actually means
like in a good movie they cut to the
chase the beginning of most james bond
films
is not it opens up slow and there's a
little bit of
backstory and you start seeing james you
know
whatever just chilling sipping you know
whiskey on no no rocks or whatever he
drinks
and uh and just chilling no the opening
in the movie is like
and he's on like a jet ski he's got like
you know
some kind of automatically skiing down a
mountain the opening of the movie is the
chase
and then they cut back to the backstory
come on quentin tarantino pulp fiction
and so
when you're crafting a powerful hook you
want to just get right into the
the content come on drake 0 to 100 real
quick
so think about how you can open up the
video powerfully if you're just teaching
think about how you can open up the
video
clearly with what's coming up and we saw
that analytic from youtube telling us
here's how many people are still
watching at 30 seconds
before you win the battle of getting
people to watch your whole video try to
boost how many people make it
through the first 30 seconds of your
video tip number two
talk fast or faster and use video
editing
now hear me this does not mean that
there aren't youtube channels
that have a slower pace to them
sometimes you might hear
asmr at a very slow and soothing pace
sometimes there's videos that are more
reflective or meditative and that could
be very effective especially
consider the viewer's intent what is it
they expect but most people
have this modern energy of just wanting
the information fast we don't want to
wait around and if we feel like there's
a moment of
we're not getting what we came for then
we may want to speed up to hold
attention
it doesn't mean you have to be super
frantic it doesn't mean you have to be
crazy
but studies have been done to actually
count
words per minute and that the higher
words per minute
on youtube usually holds attention
better than lower words
per minute and another way to do this is
with video editing
it could be as simple as you just talk
at your normal pace in your normal tone
but there's a level of jump cutting that
sort of cuts out the ums and the breaths
and this is a pace in the cadence that
you're going to want to determine for
your
yourself but it's certainly a tip that
could
help people just stick with it because
the information's coming
fast enough that they do not get bored
tip number three
use a script or an outline prior
planning prevents poor
performance when you start a video you
get into a video
if it's disorganized if it doesn't if
it's disorganized and you lose people on
the journey
then that might be the moment they
bounce because
again it was you were able to cut that
part out but you didn't really plan it
out ahead so like that's when people
lost attention if you have a good
outline an orderly outline
a logical outline or a good story curve
or story arc
then that's going to help you hold
attention by scripting your videos ahead
of time
they're going to be a lot more powerful
at the time of recording this i'm live
on our think media podcast channel and
the only reason i'm able to deliver
the information this way is i'm actually
teaching off of a powerpoint
that i pre-planned so i stay organized
and at least hopefully hold your
attention
longer because if you're hearing me say
that you are still here and maybe it's
working but consider
using a script or an outline number four
trim the fluff
man one of the best ways you can make
your content stronger
i learned from jizza from the wu-tang
clan
and he said too many rappers rhymes are
mad
long keep it brief son half short and
twice
strong and that's the tip you want to
keep it half short
and twice strong thank you gizza thank
you the wu tang
and so trim the fluff how could you make
your 10 minute video five minutes
how could you make your eight minute
video six minutes
is there any parts in your video that
are unnecessary
what can you take away ask yourself is
this essential to the video
nobody watching it is going to know it's
gone they're only going to know what
they see when you finally present it to
them
so trim the video down trim the fluff
and
the key here is continue to post videos
as you have been but then study your
audience retention curve
study how much average view duration
you're getting see
how you're holding people's attention
and if you can notice a tip or a
trend from where people are always
dropping off
then consider eliminating that from your
video and on your next upload it'll be
even better tip number five add visuals
one of the best ways to hold attention
longer is to not just potentially
not monotonously just have one thing
happening
you know i'm streaming this live using
stream yard
and i'm able to add visuals because of
the software this at least helps a
little bit but in post
we could make little pop-up you know
like button things little subscribe
things
transitions music transitions those
types of things
should not be overused but they can they
can help
keep attention longer and so consider
adding visuals like graphics and
pop-ups and extra footage called b-roll
and things like that
that strengthen your video and then tip
number six out of seven
tips is use drama conflict open loops
and curiosity
so one of the ways you could hold
attention and even if you're going
longer
at this point um i'm 23 minutes into a
video
live streaming um one of the things i
hoped to do at the beginning of the
video is during the hook i said man i'm
coming
i'm sharing seven tips i'm going to be
sharing some new features from youtube
hopefully opening up some curiosity to
make you want to be a part of more of an
educational tutorial like this
in more of entertainment you want to
potentially use drama consider how
reality tv shows
start they don't start with again when
kim and khloe kardashian are getting
along
and it's like kim and chloe peacefully
walk through a park nobody wants to
watch that
it's like kim like throws a piece of pie
across the kitchen and breaks a plate
and it's like coming up on
with kardashians chloe i can't believe
that you did that
they what do they do they cut to the
most dramatic part so potentially you
want to tease the drama you want to
create a little conflict on the opening
you want to create some open loops like
maybe there's a question at the
beginning you're going to answer at the
end
maybe you're doing a tutorial and you're
saying you know
this is what the end result is going to
be i'm going to show you how to get
there and people are like wait a minute
how'd they achieve that result
and you unfold that throughout the video
this is ultimately using
tools from storytelling that can really
power up your videos and keep attention
longer
and how can you create curiosity how can
you tease what's coming
to make the video more interesting and
maybe make people want to stick around
till the end and tip number seven is
build your personal brand
and reputation what do i mean by this
one of the things i mean by this
is i want you to consider if you're just
starting on youtube and let me know how
many videos have you posted so far and
how many subscribers do you have
if you're just starting nobody knows you
yet
i recommend if you're just starting keep
your videos shorter because
people could get to know you speed
dating they may not want to get married
yet you know what i mean like it's just
a little bit of a shorter relationship
up front
but once people get to know you then
there might be some pre-existing
trust when it comes to your content this
is sort of the unspoken
rule on youtube see if you don't have a
good reputation yet your reputation is
potentially just neutral
so you may have to use more b-roll
or or really structure your content or
really edit it
to whatever degree of influence i've
built and you can let me know if i've
ever added value to you or if you've
seen a past video or how long have you
been a part of the think community
at some level if you start to trust me
and recognize that hopefully when i
go live get on camera i bring really
value that i've
invested blood sweat and tears in
research my experience the think media
team
our collective youtube brain all this
different stuff that we work together on
that you might actually give me some
forgiveness this is why you might be
like
why does this person have such good
average view iteration of people because
people don't know you yet
but as you build your personal brand and
as you build your reputation
people begin to know and trust you more
so that
they may without the fancy barrels and
whistles stick with you because they
know you're good for it
so the actionable point of tip number
seven is just
consider giving it always your best shot
to deliver quality to people develop a
reputation if you're a teacher or expert
or author or marketer and you're kind of
more education like think media
for being brief being bright being fun
and then being done and when people say
okay
because of my past experience with you i
know that if i click on a sean cannell
youtube video or a nolan youtube video
or a heather taurus
youtube video or an omar el taquori
youtube video
that they really have put their heart
into this it's gonna probably not be a
waste of my time
and that's about building that is the
bigger vision of building a personal
brand and a reputation
that is beyond tactics because a little
subscriber
pop-up is not going to change the game
for your youtube channel those
tactics are good but a strong personal
brand
and reputation in your industry for the
promise of your
channel is gonna supersede those
other tactics let me know what was the
one you need to work out
work on the most out of these tips on
your videos
do you think it's crafting a powerful
hook number one do you think it's you
need to talk a little faster or
do video editing do you need to start
scripting or outlining your videos
do you need to trim the fluff and are
your videos a little long-winded and you
could probably take about
50 out and they would be that much
stronger
um do you need to add visuals and b-roll
do you want to start trying to use drama
conflict open loops curiosity
or are you just in the perseverance of
building your personal
brand and reputation and i want to
encourage you this was a lot of
things to do could feel overwhelming
remember we always say here at think
media
just get one percent better with every
upload it's small tweaks lead to giant
peaks
this is youtube we're on a journey this
is a this is a climb
of getting little uh a little bit better
video by video
upload by upload because this is a skill
set that takes time and it's hard to
develop
and it's ever evolving so don't be hard
on yourself don't compare yourself to
anybody else
but just focus on punching fear in the
face punching perfectionism in the face
and pressing record and then with every
single upload
seek to get one percent better and when
you look back you'll be like
man my videos have really improved
especially
as i have applied these tips
if you begin value smash likey
and uh question of the day how many
videos have you posted on youtube
so far what is your subscriber situation
so far and what is your goal this is the
coffee with cannell show welcome back
um i'm coming to you from las vegas
nevada and uh fired up to be here with
you i've got some
brandy wine coffee made with an
aeropress
and a fellow grinder brandywine is from
wilmington deli where
delaware and i had this coffee shipped
up
out to me let me know what you're
drinking
but um we're at half the halfway point
y'all
it's about to be july 20
which is exactly halfway through the
year
so i want to encourage you i really
believe the second half of the year
could be better than the first half
but we got to work for it we got to be
more focused we got to set goals
so i have a question for you coffee with
candle crew what is one of your goals
for the second half of the year
and whether you feel like you're down by
20 points where you feel like it's tied
up or whether you feel like you're ahead
i really believe that as we lock and
load come on we get our mind right our
grind on our hustle
fixed our vision focused that the second
half of the year could be really
powerful and i'd love to this is a good
time to kind of do some goal setting
come on mid-week come on in this moment
where we could really think about
all right man i'm gonna i'm gonna come
back like a phoenix
in the second half of the game and
absolutely crush it
so uh uh let me know we're gonna bring
some people on for q a but today's
coffee
channel is brought to you by
thinkmasterclass.com i did just record a
new
uh update to this at the time of
you hearing my voice right now on the
show we have a very limited
replay that is available until july 3rd
at midnight and the web class is free
but that will come down at that on july
3rd saturday night at midnight
and at the end of the class i talk about
our course called video ranking academy
and so i want you to know that just to
know that there's no like
smoke and mirrors it's like that's where
we serve people at the highest level
like
we have built a course and group
coaching community
called video ranking academy it's a
private facebook group the whole think
media team is involved
tony does the tip of the week it's a
massively vibrant community there's
nothing else like it on the internet
um but it's not for everybody and
especially if you don't want to be a
part of it so definitely watch
watch the free class at the end i tell
you a little bit more about that but
there is a very special
extra bonus that we're doing that all
ends this coming
saturday uh in the package that we're
offering at the end of this class so if
you want details on that make sure to
register
even if you want to hang out with me on
coffee with kennel right now head to
thinkmasterclass.com
so you get um the class sent to you the
on-demand replay
and you get notifications before this
special ends because if you're
at all interested you're not gonna want
to miss
out i'm fired up for the show today
we're gonna be bringing on some guests
we've got
laura coming on in just a second and
we've got spectrum art studio
uh but how you doing let me know what's
been happening in your life and if
you've got a question
uh go ahead and drop four question marks
before and after your question
smart test drive massive gratitude for
the super chat
um and thank you for uh dropping that
rick i really appreciate you
um i wish i could put that up on screen
maybe i can but
i don't know if i can it's stuck at the
top of my stream yard but
it's pushed up now appreciate that um
and uh marcus says
how do you best project your future
growth
so so far social blade has been spot on
but i'm not sure
how reliable it can be well the thing
with social blade now
is youtube pulled their api away
from the subscriber count feature and so
the thing is now is you can just look on
youtube
i mean maybe this is different than what
you're saying but in case you didn't
notice that
there's a real-time subscriber count
that you can see
in your home page of your analytics and
so
that is not projecting future growth but
i think that's why socialblade
uh is not showing that because i think
youtube pulled the api
away from them um another way to project
future growth is literally just looking
at your subscribers that's how we do it
we hover right now between 29 000 and 35
000.
see it actually says i mean here's how
you oh you're not seeing
here's how you project future growth is
you can hover over this and see it says
typical is 28 000 to 39 000. i know it's
kind of small on screen
so and i would just say okay
so uh how long we're at 1.7 million
all right let me actually go the most
conservative
how long until we get to two million and
so if we go on the most conservative
let's go 28 000 not 39
because maybe we'll get there sooner so
that's 300 000 subscribers we'll need
and when we could go divided by 29 000
subscribers a month
so if we could just maintain what we're
doing it's going to take us 10.3 months
to get to 2 million subscribers and so
your past performance is probably the
best way to predict future performance
and then what you would know is well if
something extraordinary happens
that's the point of this is the two this
way i think about youtube
i think about slow and steady wins i
think about
i don't care if i get a viral video or
not even back
when i was starting solo creator by
myself in a bedroom shooting videos
it was when i went all in on youtube it
was a relatively short time where i was
making enough to support my wife and i
with a small channel we went full time
at basically 16 000 subscribers
it wasn't viral videos that were paying
the bills it's it was
the business model we built around the
youtube channel okay
so for me the viral video i wasn't
building
it wasn't hope marketing it wasn't like
prayer marketing like i hope this works
it was a system it was a repeatable
process that's what we ultimately
call as like our 7r system i think we're
the only people in the industry that
have created a proprietary framework
that is not just principle based but is
actually a proven framework
and i was figuring that out you know
really starting 10 years ago
and so the point being as as my whole
mindset was slow and steady wins
i don't care if i get a viral video i
just want to have something sustainable
however simultaneously we're playing
the game of let's try to get a viral
video like why not so why not try to get
really high click-through rate or hop on
a trend or
or hop on something at the right moment
which we do and we've had
many videos i think i've got a 5 million
viewed video and
3.5 and a bunch of 1 millions and 2
millions so some
the interesting thing is about living
principle based on the journey
and just playing the slow and steady
wins game while also going for
the grand slams if you will
then grand slams happened along the way
but once they were over we just went
back to the
the basic principles so you know it's
interesting
i realize it's pretty extraordinary that
we're on our way to 2 million
subscribers but it's also like oh wow
that's 10 months out like
okay cool and i could go i want to get
there by the end of the year
i need to get there by you know january
1st 2020
which is a growth goal
but i'm not a big fan of growth goals
i'm a big fan of action goals
what's the difference by all means set a
goal
of i want to get to a thousand
subscribers by the end of the year
that's cool
but in a way you can't control that you
technically can't control that
but you know what you can control how
many videos you post a week
how many hours of study you do a week in
reading or studying or watching other
videos or whatever
getting coached or mentored what you can
control
is my favorite kind of goal makes sense
so i think
rather than say team our goal because
now it's a think media team
is to get to two million subscribers by
the end
of 2021
which we only got six months left based
on the math
we're not going to get there who cares
why does it why does it matter if it
happens a couple months later
is time kind of just relative i realize
we're going around the sun
but what's the difference and and hear
the tension of this like it's fine set
your growth goal
but i've learned that performance goals
so if i actually want to accomplish that
which sure i would love to get to 2
million
my question is how many videos am i
committed to posting a week
my question is now how can we as a think
media team work better
together to create better content and
put out the best videos possible
how can we and just focus on growth
goals worrying less about the results
people get too hung up in the
in the results or focus more on action
goals
measurable actions less about what your
ideal weight that you want to be at
is or your you know muscle mass index or
something
and more about how many workouts are you
doing a week because if you focus on
them doing the three hour long workouts
a week
the byproduct of the action goal
is going to get you there i hope that's
helpful that was way beyond what you
were asking
i think um but uh it gets me fired up
because we're at the halfway point this
is a really good time
to maybe reset some goals to plan some
goals for the second half of the year
but i want to challenge you goals are
not just i want to be
healthy wealthy and wise that's not a
goal i guess
it is a goal but it's it's like super
vague that's like it's absolutely
meaningless like what does healthy mean
what does wealthy mean what's that's a
fi it's like a specific financial target
wealth is like a state of mind in a way
i mean
maybe that's what i think it is you're
like no it actually means we'll write
down
a number but more than that write down
the
plan to get there that could be i'm
going to save
300 a month in this particular index
fund
because i've measured that over the next
53 years that it's going to be
now we're taking action goals and not
just
whimsical goals i want a gold play
button i want a silver play button
okay oh cool i'm
i want that's it i want
more i won also but what i want to do is
take action all right we went way too
long on that hey
we have lara on coffee with kennel today
did i say your name right laura yeah
where uh where are you watching from
laura from
california awesome thanks so much for
jumping on what's your uh question today
in your channel have you shared it in
the private chat
what i haven't heard yet okay i will
definitely do that
so my question for you
so i have a mess and i don't talk fast
what do you recommend
well i think you don't need to feel that
pressure
because thank you so much for coming on
um
i think that what i would do is i would
look at
other content creators that have ms
right yeah i don't want to compare
that's
my hang up i'm like person is the devil
yeah and i mean i guess i don't mean for
you to compare
i would mean just to see that with
other people out there that again
with ms are succeeding it just proves
it's possible
because i want to be clear the fast
talking thing
is more about uh it leans towards
gen z youtubers gamers that are talking
fast the younger generation that's at a
tick tock speed
um but there's but youtube is a very
diverse platform with people of all
ethnicities backgrounds you know
life situations so the the question is
would be if other people
um which there certainly are and it'd be
what kind of content are they creating
is their channel related to living with
ms
tips on ms or is it completely different
is it based maybe on
just you know finding others because i i
think
again not i really respect you saying
you don't want to compare
but when we see somebody that's maybe in
our situation that's just a few steps
ahead it can be inspiring
and if we can keep it in that frame of
mind we say okay somebody that is
dealing with the same situation
like not trying to compare anything with
any situation but i think about
my wife and i's journey she has a
chronic illness that has
sent us through all kinds of up and down
seasons and in certain seasons i have
felt disempowered
like man how are we gonna financially
make it or deal with this or schedule or
how am i gonna
how does this affect my job and i'm in a
disempowered mindset in that moment
the flip side is i ask myself have
couples
overcome challenges together when one of
the
family members has a chronic illness
have parents overcome challenges
together if
one of their if their children's have
some type of disability and the answer
is yes
it's not insinuating that it's easy it's
not insinuating that
it's not going to be challenging but it
can give us courage
when we glean from people that can
uh that we can relate to that have they
sort of become like a template they
become a model
uh for us to just say okay and then that
can help us shape
uh shape our content strategy what kind
of content do you want to create
or what kind of content is your channel
oh no i lost your audio is that my fault
is it just me that can't heal hear
laura right now lara
oh no
so we can't hear you right now i'm going
to just have you go backstage for a
second maybe we can get your audio back
but for some reason we lost the audio
but i hope that was helpful
um a few tips and i really do
appreciate you but it brings up a great
point
the seven tips we share in this video
are really just principles
people succeed you they're not even
rules they're principles
but the important thing to know is like
if there's rules for youtube success
it's okay to break them
you just need to know that that's what
you're doing you know what i mean
there's it's very difficult to make any
really broad stroke
so the principle is that typically with
more words per minute
that your youtube channel across the
platform which is a lot of younger
generation watching
that is used to that really fast-paced
kind of gen z
cadence that that performs better but it
also you don't have to like
i shared seven tips you don't have to do
all seven
like if you did six out of the seven
you're gonna be crushing if you did
four out of the seven if there's visuals
there and there's drama
comedy curiosity if over time
with video editing you make the video
more powerful if you trim the fluff
because video editing allows whatever
speed you're talking at to potentially
so just consider leaning into as many
tips as possible
um and you don't have to do all seven
that would be it's
it'd be insane to do all seven but just
pick one and level up as you go we got
spectrum art studio on
uh hey how's it going and what's your
name
and how can i help today
oh no we don't have the right source of
audio selected
um if you go on stream yard to cam
mic and then there's like a little gear
then you can select your camera
uh which we saw and then also get your
audio on there
as well all right we're going to have
nate
up in just a second and
smash like if you're getting value for
the technical difficulties out here
and if you ever want to come on coffee
with cannell just a couple tips
obviously we could maybe do a better job
of saying when we're gonna come on
but the dream is try to be on good wi-fi
or internet
try to have a good camera or your
smartphone on wi-fi
and try to get a good source of audio
going maybe a usb mic but your
smartphone is good enough
definitely that audio connection is good
and if possible try to be in like a more
quiet room
because smartphone in like a bedroom is
good versus smartphone
on the corner of times square in new
york city like it's just louder there
like there's more background noise
in new york city all right nate how's it
going
mind stummer mindstormer yeah
mind stormer yep so
here i'll put my in the chat there
so um my channel is
about positive gaming and i like to
game on stream and i have a side series
i'm also doing
as well actually i have two of them one
of them is about
strictly the positivity of certain games
and then
one of them i just play for fun just
doing a walkthrough
and it's on the topic of metroid which
perfect timing
um metroid game is coming out
oh yeah yep um are you going to cover
that game then too as well even though
a lot of these are the classic oh yeah
yeah i plan to
cover it at one point um so i'm going to
go through much i didn't do that but my
actual question today is so the
my v views on my live streams which is
actually the terraria live streams there
is um kind of random
and i'm kind of wondering how i can help
it to be
a little bit more
even or try to get help get more seen
so i feel like uh live streams are just
not
seen as much maybe that's just
something i'm doing but i i don't know
yet
what uh describe for
me the value you want the viewer to
experience
when they watch your videos
um kind of so that's kind of a
too uh two wounded question because i
have
um two parts of my channel
and one of them is more about positivity
and walkthroughs the other part is
blind playthroughs which i don't know
anything about the game
so it's kind of like the the more
experienced people
or the new people can experience the
game with me at the same time and that's
why i do it live
so it's a more personal person
and i i really like it and a lot of my
fan base
sure seems to like it as well so
describe
your ideal viewer like who do you think
who is the person who likes your blind
playthroughs the most
which are live oh
um probably the people who
have actually gone through and played
the game and
want to come back and see others um play
it as well
but sometimes yeah what
um is there anybody else doing what
you're doing as far as like terraria or
anything like that
yeah so well okay
um there's obviously bigger creators
that
do torria um but
since i'm doing a blind it's kind of an
odd spot
which i haven't seen a lot of and also
doing it live there's not a whole lot of
live terraria um so it's kind of an open
space but at the same time it's like
um almost a blind spot as well
so that's a double edge
have you studied the terraria videos
that have gotten the most views
and thought about why they get the most
views
yeah that's that's one of the things
that i like to think about quite a bit
and it's kind of a short editing
um quick videos rather than streams
since
kind of interesting to try to match up
to them
um yeah but it sounds like you have a
really good unlock there which was
you just told me that the videos you've
studied that get the most
views and terraria content are shorter
edited down and they get the most views
and then you're saying you're a little
bit trying to get more views on longer
live streams so it kind of goes back to
what your ambition is
you know what is your
if we're having a conversation
three years from now what would have to
happen
to make you completely happy with the
results you've gotten on youtube
i'm gonna be honest a thousand
subscribers
is gonna be great but to have a constant
fan base
that is gonna be really nice
um again it's just that
i feel like it's a separation between my
channel
but i it's the thing is i really
enjoy doing it so i enjoy continuing
with this live streams and
make making gaming content it's
all part of a dream
well i like your clarity and so i think
it sounds it sounds like you're doing it
right
and i would double down on what you're
doing there's two types of videos i want
you to keep focusing on
the first thing you said was i love
doing these live streams
that's the depth i want to connect with
people
at at the greatest level and you're
saying you'd want a fan base
that is constant for these blind
walk-throughs and i love that vision
that's to build a community
you're playing new games that you
haven't played you're experiencing it
together
and let's make a goal to have a thousand
people on those live streams
not a thousand subscribers only but a
thousand people on those live streams
it's kind of a good goal we talk about
this on our free class a thousand true
fans
and would you agree that if you had and
let's say it never grew bigger than that
but you had a community of
approximately a thousand people that
really not just
connected with your content but
connected with each other would that
that be success wouldn't it oh yeah that
like i said this a dream that i'm
working towards
and i want to exceed so then
what i want you to do though and this is
a good unlock for not just you but for
everybody watching
in order to find what some people call
like
build your tribe your your tribe online
you know um
group of of people you're a thousand
true fans
you need to oftentimes reach hundreds of
thousands if not millions of people
um and the reason i bring that up
is because i want you to lean in on the
content that's going to get you exposure
to new people
but you also need to be aware of that 99
out of 100
or not even that good are not going to
want to be a super fan
they're going to want to just watch a
quick video they're going to want to
watch
some quick tips um just
for example in think media
i don't know if we can find this stat
but let's try to find
our impressions in the lifetime of the
channel
1.4 billion impressions
so that's how many people have seen our
videos maybe not have clicked on them
and that has only led only to 125
million views i would actually argue
that our core community
is probably 10 000 or less people
so a billion people have had the chance
to see our stuff
125 million have maybe gotten value but
like didn't want to really connect
and it trickled all the way down to some
people that are like oh yeah i love
think media
you know i love coffee with ken or
whatever so
the action item then is to i would say
lean more on
growth videos while continuing to do
your live streams
videos that are going to be edited down
that are going to get views that have
the chance to get
five thousand ten thousand fifteen
thousand views where you're
looking at trends you're making maybe
top ten
secrets or ways to get treasure from
under so forgive me for not knowing the
details about the game like whatever
the types of videos that bring in new
audience new potential viewers
and then recognize that it's only a
portion of those that are really going
to stick with you but that's like the
dream of this
and and it makes total sense like we
say your vibe will attract
your tribe like not everyone's gonna
vibe with you not everyone's gonna
connect with you that's okay
we need to be okay with people coming
into our youtube channel checking out
looking around seeing what's happening
maybe even being a fan for a while
a lot of people in think media that's
the thing they have a certain pain point
they have certain problems and we they
binge think media for two months three
months six months
and they're like cool thanks think media
thanks for helping and they're on but
there is a core
group let me know if you're in the
comments right now and you're like dude
i've been watching you
since you were shooting videos in your
bedroom sean you know i'm
i'm an og thinker you know
that's a very small percentage of people
and i think it's being okay with that
and so let me know if that makes sense
if your end goal
is to eventually build this diehard
group that loves to vibe and watch these
blind playthroughs together
then i would lean on top line
growth because it's a percentage of that
that will eventually make it to that
show
and really want to hang out with you on
a regular basis does that make sense
yeah yeah yeah it does and that actually
kind of makes more sense as
why my views are the way they are in
reality
so yeah awesome nate well i appreciate
you thanks so much for coming on
yeah thank you
we are on coffee with keno smash like if
you're getting value
we're gonna try spectrum art studio
again um
on the show but let me ask you a
question
and that is this if you and i we're
having a discussion just like this on
coffee with kennel
three years from now what would have to
happen
in on your youtube channel to make you
happy
with the results what would that look
like for you three years from now
is it a subscriber goal is it an amount
of money per month
we're having this discussion three years
from now what would be
what would make what would make you feel
fulfilled and happy
let me know in the comments um and uh
i would love to hear your answer
spectrum art studio
you're here we got the audio
amazing i'm from the uk okay
my name is kirsten and um i started this
channel um last september after watching
your challenge
um and i was actually watching it for my
son's channel he's 10 years old
and i was inspired by heather um
to start an art channel she was talking
about lots of things to do with
education
and i thought i'm going to start an art
education channel because is this your
channel
that's right got it um and the banners
um in flux at the moment because i'm
i've
changed from our spectrum art academy
and i've gone to spectrum arch
so i'm in the process of changing over
um
and that's it that's what i'm in the
process of doing my question
is i think well my retention
or my average view duration is quite low
at the moment it's about
30 percent between 20 and 30
and i think it may be my voice it's
quite slow
because you mentioned about you know
speed of voice um
i've had a couple of people at the
beginning were saying it was quite fast
so i've been experimenting with
the speed of my voice i did try and keep
it quite so but then
what i do in between is i play music so
i do a little bit of speaking and then a
bit of music
so i appreciate your feedback on what i
should do with that
excellent i'm going to listen here no
no
so um first of all uh
love the kind of peaceful um you know
kind of more piano music
and this is a great question to bring up
during this training i know my second
tip
was you know talk faster i do not want
that to be misinterpreted
it depends on your niche and
in a tutorial there's no need to fill
the dead space
there's no need to rush and speak too
fast i don't
this kind of content in my opinion does
not necessitate
um needing to talk faster
yeah um having that more it is it's also
to me
even you know watching you draw this
with some music is
is therapeutic it's something that i
could maybe follow along with
and so i believe you're doing that
exactly right
i think that um first let's just kind of
we're here but let's look over here
one it's great that you have growth 73
new subscribers
looks like it's saying four videos a
month
and around 5 200 views so you're doing
great
one of the things i like to always ask
is
what are your top performing videos and
what can you learn from them success
leaves clues
so make part twos yeah a youtube
short on how to draw something looks
like it did very well which is
cool to see i've also got i've also
started recently started a shorts
channel
um so why not keep it on the same
channel
because i felt that the
non so i've got a bit of a strategy in
that i'm keeping
i'm starting to do celebrity portraits
and trending portraits so i don't know
if you've noticed i've done one of the
black widow
because there's a black widow so um
i'm starting to move towards doing
trending
you know doing techniques and doing
the the technique part of it so that
someone's learning something but then
doing
something trending i was going to do
low-key but i left that a bit late
so i'm picking i don't know why personal
opinion i don't think it should be on a
different channel
okay right i mean i was going to check
this video
okay right so because i i did what i did
was i
started a separate channel and i was
just doing just purely technique one so
i did
six different skin tones and i do them
as tick tocks as well
so i've got tick tocks so i put them
across as tick tocks as well
but and the shorts channels is for just
purely the techniques whereas if i'm
doing
a celebrity portrait one i will keep
that on my channel to bring people to my
channel
to see the the longer form one if that
much should probably
be confusing but if it's j if it hasn't
got like a
a celebrity portrait thing to it that
goes just to the shorts channel but
i literally just started that about a
month ago so i'm just playing with that
but i have been doing the shorts for a
while
and i have found that they are very
successful
within my channel yeah and obviously
shorts are kind of die not dying out but
they're kind of leveling out now if that
makes sense
so if we were having this discussion
three years from today
and you were looking back over these
past three years
what would have happened on your youtube
channel both both personally
uh both professionally and what would
happen in your in your personal life
that would make you happy with your
progress
well i've also started doing patreon
um so what you what you're seeing here i
know it's kind of leaving youtube
but i think as you've said pre when i've
watched your channel previously you need
to have like multiple streams right
so there you go you found it um so i've
started to put content on there
you have any patreon patrons yet no
um so that is taking up a lot of my time
making the content for that
um but obviously it's just growing so
hopefully in time that will
um take off so
so tell me so what what's what's
happened personally and professionally
that you feel happy with your progress
three years from now
well hopefully i can make a living out
of this
that's what i would that's where i would
like to be
make a living so
the thing to work on is to reverse
engineer back
right from three years from now what is
essentially my shortest path to making a
living of course
inspiring making the world better
through art you know sharing your gifts
and talents what you're doing is amazing
um but but it's also working backwards
financially
um in my opinion with where you're at
right now i want
you to focus on one word and
here's how you spell it f o
c u s i want you to focus on focus
follow one course until successful you
know what's interesting that you just
told me
is you already have one youtube channel
that you're trying to keep up with
you've got the four uploads
a month it looks like um and
you just told me that even with this one
youtube channel your plan is to start
another youtube channel
but you've already started a patreon and
it's taking a ton of your time to keep
your patreon updated
but no one's signed up for your patreon
yet so
you're already doing too much yeah my
goal for you right now is to just
eliminate and focus
on um you know there's there's probably
10 20 35 steps to your journey of
making a living from your youtube
channel but you really don't need to be
working on step 13
when you should be focusing on step one
and two
and in my opinion that is keeping all of
your videos under one roof
uh on the one channel it's not worrying
about the monetization things like
patreon yet
it's good that you have that in mind but
it's focusing on influence first because
influence comes
first income comes second and so
i would i would try to put your
quote-unquote head down
focusing on making great content putting
out great videos
creating a system of making your one
channel great
trying to say no to everything else
trying not to get too distracted on
social media
um and to really grow
your youtube channel uh and to see how
much you can also learn
um in that process and make it a uh
make it a goal to get to five ten
thousand subscribers before starting
patreon for everybody listening
if you're like and whatever other
monetization streams if you're like yeah
but i wanna monetize right away hear me
i get it and and that's fine is it a
magic number of 5 000 subscribers before
you started or not no but the biggest
mistake
that i see creators make in our
community every single day
is they're like hey should i get merch
going right now and they haven't got
momentum
on their channel yet should i you know
should i start crowdfunding right now
but they haven't got momentum on their
channel yet therefore
step one is get the momentum going step
one
step two is get videos going out
consistent step three
is get your influence building and
when you've got quote unquote enough
influence
sean what's the exact number don't even
quote me on the number but let's just
say 10
000 subscribers you're gonna
and you then make a video inviting
people to your patreon
you can go from zero patrons to 25
a lot easier than exactly what you just
told me
it's taking the most energy to keep it
updated or get it set up and all this
stuff
and that energy that should be invested
in
the core focus
yeah all in one course until successful
of getting your channel off the ground
launching a youtube channel is kind of
like a rocket launch in my opinion
and if you've ever watched a spacex or a
you know nasa rocket launch
the rocket is on the earth and all of a
sudden
boom all this jet fuel comes out of the
rocket
and all this you know the the
afterburners and
it doesn't move at first it doesn't even
move
and then it moves slowly just to get the
rocket lifting up
and then the goal is to break through
the atmosphere ultimately
during that rocket launch what they say
and don't quote me nasa scientists but
that something like
over 75 of the jet fuel or something is
burnt
in the first launch like in the
beginnings of that rocket taking off
like immediately it's that
tons of energy of getting the momentum
going of getting the channel going of
getting the thing going
and then eventually breaks through the
you know atmosphere ozone layer whatever
all the nasa scientists are offended
because i don't know what i'm saying but
you get the analogy
and now you're able to maintain the
thrust or maintain the velocity
because of the initial effort exerted
the key is
if that if those afterburners were going
out of the sides
out of the top in multiple different
directions the
rocket would not uh would be
spreading its energy too thin it's a
focus blast out of the afterburners to
get the rocket going in one direction
to break through the atmosphere and i
want you to hear that i want us all to
hear that again
getting your youtube channel up and off
the ground consistently putting out
your best videos needs your best brain
power your best creativity
your your you studying what you're doing
billy eilish studying who's like what's
happening and studying
what other channels in your niche what's
working but focusing on that core
content first
because the power of youtube is once you
have momentum there's just an absolute
insane amount of evergreen traffic
continuous traffic on your channel
which gets you freedom to work on other
things to build out the patreon to build
out a website to build out an online
course to
set something up and the problem is too
many people start working on all those
all those other things way too soon if
you look at
think media using this plugin called bid
iq that gives me this trending tab
these videos have view vph this is
velocity i've launched
hundreds of rockets right and
they're in space flying for me i have a
fleet
of videos that are growing our business
our brand and awareness
so that today i can write the next book
i'm writing so that today
i can take a break and rest a little bit
so today but a lot of energy it took a
lot of energy to get the growth the
momentum the quality of videos and all
these videos have vph views per hour
so i know you get the idea and you get
the dream but i think it's a good theme
for you to hear
and i want coffee to count with kennel
to hear this as well especially as we go
into the second
six months of the year what do you need
to stop doing
what can you cancel off of your to your
plate today
and what can you just put on the back
burner if anybody if you ever do any
cooking
back burners where you just put it on
simmer you put on the back burn it's not
the main thing you're applying the heat
to the chicken the soup's already good
to go so that's just on simmer on the
back burner
patreon on the back burner other
platforms on the back burner
if you're doing a youtube short and also
putting it on tick tock and even reels
well cool because you're optimizing
your efforts in that regard but trying
to do too much
other social media that could be
distracting your focus away from
youtube which is different than all the
other social media
i want to elon musk spacex my rocket
and focus all my jet fuel in getting
liftoff breaking through so that i can
create the freedom to pull
patreon off the back burner to create my
art course to
you know get those other income streams
and in a way
the way to get to your goal which you
told me in three years
um of making a living or sooner
is to simplify and is to really think
about
you might say these are going to be my
next 15 moves like chess like a chess
master thinks multiple moves ahead
but they're not making move 15 today
they only have to focus on the next move
in the next three moves
and in a way put their blinders on to
everything else is that making sense is
that helpful
totally yeah it's very valuable advice
because i'm spending too long making
these patreon videos so
that's amazing thank you for everything
you do
so grateful for you and uh really love i
mean your art
skills are amazing and it's really cool
to see your channel
and uh and i love what you've done so
far i really think you've
you're almost to a thousand subscribers
so congrats on all of the results you've
had and thanks for being a part of one
of our challenges
i'm so excited because when you apply
even more focus to what you're doing the
growth is going to go faster because
that's more jet fuel deployed
against the main thing which is your one
youtube channel
thank you appreciate you thanks for
coming on thank you
thanks can anybody else relate
to the need of focus
uh type focus in the comments if you can
in a second we have her healthy home
coming on the show
coffee with kennel though my name is
sean cannell i'm the author
co-author of a book called youtube
secrets i don't have any copies of it i
just have this one
uh this is the korean translation it's
been cool this book has been translated
into
uh russian ukrainian what's the language
of the ukraine
um i i believe both
five six seven eight languages now i
hope to get the other physical copies of
it
but youtube secrets um
smash like if you're getting value
today's episode is brought to you by if
you want to you know learn how to make a
youtube plan of growth
learn how to create those unstoppable
views and you haven't seen our free
class
we have a special replay that is
available for a few more days at
thinkmasterclass.com link in the
description down
below um we've got focus in the chat
today
come on focus is hard i i feel you
follow one course until successful
though randall focus
focus is a superpower it's a difference
maker
i can't focus lol i mean that's and i
feel you
i mean focus is will give you an
edge in a modern world where distraction
is becoming commonplace youtube creators
and entrepreneurs that um
can master the discipline of focus
and of knowing not just what to say yes
to but what to say no to
are those that are are actually just
going to succeed
period i hate to be this blunt about
this but if you can't get focused
you may never succeed on youtube
because you're doing too many things at
once um
it's just kind of like if i want to go
on a trip
over the next week with my family my son
shot
sean bradley and my wife sonia um
pretty soon we're going to be headed to
seattle and we're in vegas so that's
that's north west from us right now
florida is south
east from us where right now here's the
thing
if we want to go on vacation this week
we go
to mccarran airport here in las vegas
and we say
i want a ticket and they say where do
you want to go
i say seattle florida
they go seattle or florida i mean both
i want to i want to go to both they go
well we're gonna have to cut you in half
then because that's on two opposite
sides of the united states
yeah but i want to do both they say
we couldn't we i need to know you give
you one ticket like where do you want to
go
and there's no connecting flights
between seattle and florida
because they're on two opposite sides so
you got to pick where you want to go
friend where do you want to go and if
you're trying to go too many places at
once now hear me
i set our vacation in the next week
which where where do you want to go can
my wife
and family can we go to seattle in the
next week and then take another week
in florida and then take and then fly
over the ocean and go to europe the week
after
sure so over time you can go multiple
places
so you may have heard it said that you
can do anything
you just can't do everything right
you can't do because if you try to do
everything at once you'll accomplish
nothing so you can do anything you just
can't do everything
but i want to encourage you i actually
think you could do everything
just not all at once so if you want to
write a book and build a course and
start a second channel
do you know how many channels i want to
start did you know
that on my sean cannell channel there's
probably not a run i go on i run like
three days a week
so i'm running and i'm always thinking
about things
on my sean candle channel i'm thinking
about i want to talk about like business
leadership and faith
and i want to consistently upload videos
there and i don't post anything on that
channel right now just my personal brand
channel
and so running think media being
faithful with what's in my hands today
you know realizing that there's a whole
team sharing some of those elements on
our podcast and different things
my discipline you don't understand the
creative pull to want to work on that
channel
it is like there's not like a day that i
don't think about but discipline says
it's just not the right time
i can't go to florida and seattle at the
same time but i can go to both places
eventually especially if i'm
really focused on making what i'm doing
today work
because when i focus on what i'm doing
today work it means we have more views
it means we have more money
it means we have more team we have more
systems and more automation
on the think media business if you will
which gives me
freedom to work on the next project
your problem is you're trying to work on
four businesses and six projects all at
once
and that will stunt or completely stop
your success
it is funny i hate to go off on this
rant and we have another person coming
on
but some people will be like yeah well
elon musk runs
spacex and he runs tesla and he runs
solarcity well number one elon musk has
unlimited
money so he can hire people and put them
in leadership
number two total respect he has a
horrible quality of life
like how do you run multiple businesses
work
15 16 17 18 hours a day
well elon why even comparing yourself to
elon like zero people were
like so the point is there's a proverb
that says instead of carrying two things
with two hands
carry one thing with two hands
and the proverb was actually about if
you were like carrying two things
and you stumbled you actually might drop
both or drop one
but if you're carrying two things down a
rocky path
you got i'm not gonna drop this water i
got more balance my whole focus is on
one thing
most creative entrepreneurs i know are
trying to carry 18 things they're like
they're got
it's like this and i got my book that
i'm writing
i got my course okay oh and then and
then you're coming on like and i'm
thinking about starting
a new thing okay what else do i got here
okay all right get my bible
all right just out here focused yeah i'm
just a multi-passionate entrepreneur
i'm just i just have a lot of things i'm
working on that's not
a badge of success that is a signal
of overwhelm and distraction dear god i
just dropped every i just dropped my
phone i just dropped my iphone
i bet it's broken and that's what
happens when you carry too many things
is you drop things and they break it's
fine i have carpet listen
are you getting value out of this if you
haven't typed focus yet type focus
i'm i'm telling you this will help you
if you want the next six months to be
your best six months and to really crush
it in 2021 i'm asking you to stop doing
some stuff
i'm asking you to get focused and i'm
asking you to realize
your energy your time is limited
i'm actually not asking you to work less
if you want to work like elon and work
15 16 17
hours a day devote all that energy to
one thing
you'll get that one thing momentum or
profitability or impact quicker
by focusing this is the public enemy
number one of this decade
is distraction of is overwhelm is too
many opportunities
too many choices too many social media
platforms
i'm here to really push you towards
youtube but like it does i'm not even
saying whatever you do
just be focused be clear on what you're
you're picking what your thing is i'm
going to quote dr phil
and you know what dr phil he put it this
way he said god
gave you he said you got to pick a horse
and write it
god gave you one ass so you can't ride
two horses
pick a horse ride it come on
come on genuine anybody catch that
reference listen pick a horse
and ride it you only got one butt dr
phil
focus all right uh
her healthy home is on the show today
how's it going good to see you
uh what's your name uh khadijah
khadijah yes thank you so much for
coming on
um how can i help today um i feel like
you would probably
say that i need to niche down but then i
heard you say
don't focus on another channel and i
just have so many things i want to do
so yeah so
what's going right now and and are you
happy with the results dissatisfied with
the results
um because i do so many different things
each video will
shoot different so um i guess that's
what i can expect i'm all over the
places so
so ours is everything else
okay and so is your question on how to
get focused or just general advice on
youtube if you should
niche down or what i would do if i was
you yeah
yeah if i said niche down um
yes well it's i always go with it says
home so it can be
inside the home it might be outside the
home doing all kinds of things cooking i
do preserving
gardening um homes like homemaking
but then i say it probably is best to do
one thing
and then of course i have my faith which
is really important and i just don't
want to give that up but i feel like
i'd go further if i did yeah
well here's one thing that doesn't get
talked about enough
um and actually a video i would
recommend watching
um is we just posted a clip from vanessa
lau who spoke at our conference growth
video live
by the way we have a conference coming
up if you haven't heard about it growth
videolive.com it's virtual that's
in the end of august uh but vanessa lau
spoke there last year and she talked
about niching down
one of the mistakes people make is they
think
that the niche only means something like
daniel fast
like this channel is only about daniel
fasts you know what i mean like
that's and and in my opinion that's
actually sort of a big
big topic but that's that's almost too
niche
i mean a certain type of cooking and
eating healthy vegan is probably like
vegan living is probably clear
but like daniel fast would be like too
specific but the whole other way to
think about niche is not about the
content and the topics but it's about
the person
you're trying to reach the niche
is the audience so there's a magazine
called gq and i sometimes like to
encourage people
to think about their youtube channel
like a magazine now when people think
about gq magazine they know exactly what
it is they're like oh yeah men's fashion
but it's like a channel that's like for
this sophistic or a youtube
it's a magazine that's for like the
sophisticated
man right but on
in their magazine you open it up and one
thing
every episode has magazine every issue
is style tips best outfits for summer
best accessories but then throughout it
they've got
interviews with men that are in
hollywood or that are in non-profits
and so there seems to be something that
okay 54 new menswear items under 100
uh a box subscriptions but then
how fast and furious character became a
lightning rod so so it's like
entertainment but it's all under gq
and people who understand what gq is
it's like it's a
men's magazine and even more than that
it's kind of like
the the progressive wanting to be
well-dressed entrepreneurial
sophisticated man
so it's much different than maybe like
a magazine about uh
jeeps or hunting or fishing which would
be a different
if there's a fishing magazine it might
be the best travel spots to fish the
best reels
so my summary is who
are you talking to that's your niche
you're a dynamic person your faith is
important to you
gardening is important to you living
sustainably
maybe not harming the earth uh all of
these different things are important to
you
and there's other people like you that
want to be a part of your journey
you got 1300 subscribers obviously it's
already working
other homeschool moms in fact when you
understand the
psychographics meaning not just the
demographics the age
ethnicity background but the
psychographics is what people are into
as a homeschool mother and i'm going to
stereotype here a little bit
but stereotypes are actually good in
this context
because stereotypes usually show us a
cluster of behaviors of course people
broke those
break those rules that help us
understand
psychographics let me talk about myself
first as an
entrepreneurial youtube creator
but especially like heavy entrepreneur
people would probably
if you assumed i'd probably click on a
video about mark zuckerberg or elon musk
or jeff bezos like the big on
i would probably i probably follow tim
ferriss i probably
would read entrepreneur magazine in
success magazine i
probably would drink bulletproof coffee
or follow dave asprey
in in terms of biohacking i would
probably be
susceptible to purchase athleisure
fitness wear that's a little more
expensive
geared towards mid 30s and 40s
entrepreneur males that's understand
that's understanding
the psychographics i would probably want
to be in a particular car or not
and if someone marketed to me or had
content for me
i personally might be like ah cars don't
matter to me that much because they
actually don't i like to pay my car off
get certified pre-owned have it be under
warranty buy it a couple years old and
save the money
just my personal thing so they might
miss me on a thing or two but as a whole
to the degree that you understand the
person
is to the degree that you have actually
chosen a proper niche
so if i could and i don't have to dig
very deep to
stereotype your community because you've
said it here
but a lot of homeschool peop mothers are
forward thinking
probably want to have a garden may want
to live off the land and raise
chickens may want to sow may want to
think about prepping like cans of
preserves and i'm reading this off of
your about page
maybe you're thinking about decorations
or diy decorations
and many probably come from a faith
perspective as well
so hopefully this is an encouragement
that i actually believe
you're much more on
the right track than you may think
your niche does not need to be the
specific videos
your niche needs to be the most likely
woman you are talking to and what is she
interested in what does she want to
click on and the truth i would probably
argue then is let's think about this
she probably wouldn't click on a video
that was
10 character traits of the billionare
billionaire elon musk well that was easy
we just cut off that video
they she probably wouldn't click on how
to raise your jeep
and install mickey thompson super
swamper bogger tires on your jeep
because that's so like if you started
two hours of minecraft
game streaming she's probably not
clicking on that either so there's
actually
a ton of clarity in regards to what she
won't click on
and then there's some room where maybe
she does care about
your uh what i eat in a day vegan
carries less about the biblical garden
meditation but she's not going to
unsubscribe because of that video
because she just is kind of more into um
you know the chores toddlers can do and
so
hear me you start to clear your content
inside
of of the niche and figure out maybe you
discover
it would just be like gq being like man
whenever we write articles like this
people really love it the guys really
love it you still want to steer your
content
but i think you're absolutely on the
right pla
in the right place or going the right
direction because your niche is much
more about serving and talking about the
topics
that your ideal viewer would be
interested in clicking on
and less about feeling like you have to
make your whole
channel about you know the daniel fast
or just gardening or something like that
let me know if that makes sense any
questions on that
yeah it definitely makes sense i thought
i was going to get beat up a little bit
about
nation so it definitely changes my
perspective so i'm a little bit
motivated now so i thank you
so much for that
well absolutely and uh what i would do
is i would also then of course success
leaves clues make part twos
so it is interesting that
prepping in this case definitely
attracted some audience now that makes
sense
because maybe um especially during the
pandemics september 2020
people were interested in aspects of
that
so you might want to double down on that
furthermore looks like
maybe even you did some stimulus
prepping
and so i would look through here and
potentially steer your content
what we all need to do is it's a balance
of not completely placating the
algorithm
and only doing because the youtube
algorithm
it's almost like not to take it to the
extreme of the phrase
but like how jesus said like what good
is it to gain the world but lose your
soul
like if you only follow the youtube
algorithm you could lose your soul in
the process you're like
i just purely went for views but then
the balance of it is like
you also though want to be creating
content that people actually care about
watching
so what gets measured is like okay what
are my passions
what do i feel called to talk about and
and
what what do i want to talk about but we
also balance that out with also what do
people want to watch because if you
actually care about getting views
if you just want to talk about whatever
and if people watch it doesn't matter
does that make sense so it's a balance
between
being willing to maybe stop doing videos
even if you'd prefer to do that i've
done this a lot over the years
we have stopped certain types of topics
on think media
because think about it this way well i
wanted to make that video
okay cool but nobody wanted to watch it
so what's the what do people want to
watch
so where's the intersection of topics
i'm passionate about but are also
effective and that are really resonating
with your audience
so over the next six months that would
be my goal would be to potentially
consider
what types of videos should i stop doing
and am i okay with that because if you
feel like convicted
and like this needs to be something i
talk well then of course you should
share it but you know what i mean like
if it's not effective why don't i stop
it
okay i love this and it's effective why
don't i do more about that
and what i would encourage you is that
her healthy home
may become less about the
around 10 different things you're doing
and maybe it comes into like
five or five or so and we would call
these like content
buckets like not that you need to do
five days a week but let's assume you
were it's kind of like
gardening is really high impactful or
rather like food prep
is like meal prep tips or food prep and
all that kind of stuff that's like a day
people love the gardening tips that's
kind of like a day because those things
kind of tie together
what i eat in a day people love that and
you start to discover
that when you talk about what i eat in a
day you're sharing your faith
like you're like hey it's been a great
day i opened that you know prayed today
we got the things you know kids together
great devotionals
going through my food today like you may
not need videos on faith
i'm not saying stop doing the garden
meditations biblical garden meditations
but if they're not effective and you can
let them go
how can you weave that into your other
videos this is an
ongoing response to what's working
what do you feel passionate about and
called to do but what is also resonating
with viewers
and we should be constantly tweaking our
content strategy and not
overly romantic about some of our videos
if they're just not working
because they might not be worth doing
okay yeah
thank you for that advice i want to just
ask what bible you picked up your bible
i was trying to read what it said
this this guy yeah so this is the
john maxwell uh leadership bible and
there's two versions of it there's the
niv but there's also new king james i
really like the niv
version and i've been going cover to
cover this year so i'm
i'm about on track so um
it's absolutely amazing because it's
just a good niv version but
for leadership the breakout portions
are john maxwell one of my favorite
authors and leadership teachers coaches
so he breaks down these situations in
the bible and what we can learn as
leaders so for building a team
self-leadership what do we learn from
david and saul from a leadership
perspective and all those kind of things
and
uh i think um
i'll i'll throw a link in the
description to it but let me even see if
i can find it
it's it's probably one of my favorite or
it is my favorite bible
um since i go that angle right like
leadership is a big passion for mine and
it's something that i want to grow in
um when uh with the leading the think
media team and always trying to become a
greater leader so
you if whatever translation you want out
of
new king james or niv but i would lean
towards the
niv well that's a good price
um this is what it is bonded leather
third edition comfort print new
international version
i wouldn't go with bergen burgundy
personally
i would look for black but of course now
we're really niche into it so yeah it's
really great
good reviews too the best bible for
future leaders i would agree with that
and so if you feel called to leadership
i believe that we could all grow
in leadership uh but it is it is my
favorite the bible is my favorite book
about life and leadership uh proverbs i
read proverbs every day
but this enhanced version with those
leadership insights is also my favorite
version because
i believe that when we get better as
leaders everybody around us
gets better our kids our spouses our
friends we lift our companies
we lift our our youtube channels anyways
sorry for the rant
oh thank you no i'm sorry if i sounded i
look rude my
children are toddlers i'm trying to keep
them off the keyboard no i feel you i
got a name with the world
i'm definitely interested in that thank
you absolutely i appreciate you so much
and thanks for coming on
thank you coffee with kennel
hit the like button if you're grateful
for today and uh
yes and amen amanda hall good to see you
thanks for being here
uh my friends a couple things that are
happening first and foremost
is um is
today's episode is brought to you by
think thinkmasterclass.com
really excited about um this class we
have a replay up for a couple days
i also mentioned um you know grow
with video live and that's coming up
um in the end of august and so if you
haven't been at growth videolive.com
you could check that out and we've got
some details about the conference is a
virtual event
the lowest ticket is 97 for general
mission
and there's just some different things
in regards to the replays
different features the different ticket
levels get but it's very affordable two
full days
growwithvideolive.com we'll link
all of that up in the description down
below um and
we're going to be focusing on the
cutting edge
youtube marketing tactics getting our
mindset right for youtube
um we're going to be very intentionally
creating some environments with
zoom and with our it's called socio with
our app
where there'll be kind of a focus place
where you can meet other creators
and really build that community side
we'll have kind of some um
workshop type interactive things
happening
let me know if you were a part of growth
video live last year which was also
virtual as we were in the pandemic
and um uh
cover review says do growth video live
it's excellent so i
agree appreciate that and janna thank
you so much for being here you're
welcome i appreciate you
um next year 99
in person in vegas but we're this year
we're being smart we're still figuring
out the vibe
so august it's already locked in it's
virtual august 26th through 27th
uh 2021 uh anywhere you are in the world
um i have a vra ticket can i upgrade it
before the conference
absolutely you can always email us at
hello
at seancannell.com and we could
upgrade it is it true that vra members
get free access
yeah um when you join vra it depends
on the offer like with the special offer
we're doing right now which you hear
about at the end of
thinkmasterclass.com it includes a
virtual pass
if you have already used your pass
because you get one and maybe you join
vra back in the day or something
then if you've already used it then you
would need to buy
a ticket and then vra once you're a part
of our community like that and you've
invested in that online course
there's usually like a discount code
because
you're a part of kind of that inside
community but the best thing to check
um eleanor is going to the facebook
group and we're always doing
announcements and things in there so if
you haven't used your ticket
you you're good make sure you use it if
you have already used it then you can
buy
a new one and don't miss this year
because it's going to be awesome
absolutely denise there is and uh
inner circle gets a discount on
everything all the time and there's that
promo code
and so hit us up and we would be happy
uh you could post in the facebook group
there as well
and daisy or mel will do some updates
about that in both groups and tony will
do some updates we'll get you some news
if you're already a part of any of our
communities
yes of course you get a little bonus
extra but listen
it's at the best price publicly and
we've made it super affordable
starting at just 97 you get to be a part
of the two-day event
that includes the downloads um all of
those sessions
all of the networking and again at this
point you'd have to take my word for it
if you haven't been there but we do have
some videos that we can
show you about it and whatnot um there's
like a recap of last year
it was it was amazing we put our heart
and soul in it um it's
it's a it's a whole different level than
sean just sitting in his office
with a cup of coffee we um we have tony
areola our conference director
and we really go all out with the
quality with the content
with um our best we could pull back the
curtain on everything we're doing at
think media and the latest things we've
learned
and then it's about the connection and
community and we have a lot of
intentional things
um happening that year so
growvideolive.com
is where all the details are uh you can
see this video that'll break down all
the details
at growethvideolive.com on exactly what
to
expect from the conference you can see
this is sort of the vibe we've got kind
of like multiple studios going and a lot
of interaction going and
q a that happens and so it's a really
special event
and i encourage you to find a way to be
a part of it and you don't got to get a
plane ticket you don't got to get a
hotel room
you can engage from wherever you are in
the world did you enjoy the content
today can you hit like if you got value
out of today's video uh watch the replay
for the tips early on and how to trigger
the youtube algorithm
um and uh my
name is sean cannell rhymes with youtube
channel
our mission at think media is to help 10
000 people
um create a full-time living with
youtube and so stick with us subscribe
if you haven't subscribed
and if you want some more content right
now and you want to go a little bit
deeper
and further faster on youtube head to
thinkmasterclass.com
um to watch our free one hour class
i talk about more of what marie what vra
is there
on this class but i just recorded this
this is a brand new update
because we're at halftime y'all i
believe this second half of the year is
going to be the best half of the year
if come on we get disciplined we get
committed
we get focused and if we do all those
things i believe we can be unstoppable
with the right strategies
and so um we're here to help all right
hey i appreciate you keep crushing it
keep smashing it and we will